ce jeudi matin dans l'amphicond d'orset
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin ses étudiants anglophones
écoutent les explications de Sylvie
Faucheux il ne savent pas qu'il s'agit
de sa dernière conférence en tant que
présidente du presse Université Paris
Grand Ouest sylvie fauchu a été nommée
mercredi rectrice de l'académie de Dijon
pour une prise de fonction dès ce
vendredi une nomination expresse à prise
par sms je suis très heureuse je suis
très fière qu'on ait pensé à moi et donc
c'est un défi important de de sur sur un
nouveau territoire donc voilà donc je
c'était une surprise mais une belle
surprise faut s'organiser vite parce que
même au niveau de la au niveau
professionnel bien sûr je dirais que
j'ai pas chaué cette nuit pour essayer
de de me tirer au clair t tous les
dossiers faire aussi une passation de
mes dossiers mais aussi au niveau de la
vie privée c'est aussi une organisation
très
rapide une organisation très rapide
sylvie fauchu est depuis juillet 2012 la
présidente du pôle de recherche et
d'enseignement supérieur université
Paris Grand Ouest la semaine dernière
elle présidait une conférence inaugurale
on peut dire que le presse est sur les
rails il y a des projets qui sont lancés
il y a des groupes de travail il y a un
vrai soutien de la part des
collectivités territoriales l'ensemble
des établissements semble aller dans le
même sens donc bon je pense que ça
arrive à un moment où finalement
peut-être les nouvelles équipes des deux
présidents des deux universités
fondatrices vont pouvoir insuffler à ce
press ce que ce qu'ils souhaitent une
belle poursuite de parcours pour celle
qui a obtenu son doctorat en sciences
économiques en 90 en 2002 Sylvie fauchux
devient présidente de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin elle le restera
pendant 10 ans marquant de son empreinte
dynamique le développement de la faculté
dont on vient de célébrer les 20 ans et
qui compte aujourd'hui 16000
étudiants je sais pas s'il y a une
méthode si Faucheux bon d'abord je crois
que je suis quelqu'un d'assez
enthousiaste donc euh B quand je je
m'emp parle d'un dossier bah je le fais
avec pati bah je crois qu'ussi ça permet
d'entraîner les équipes derrière et je
bénéficie toujours en fait des d'équipes
qui qui qui ne regardent ni leur temps
ninergie Sylvie Fauch ne quittera pas
tout à fait le département elle
s'installera la semaine à Dijon avant de
revenir le weekend dans les Yveline où
elle réside elle demeure chercheur
rattaché à son laboratoire
sa